[Music]
Bachelor star Ari lion Dyke Jr cuts his
interview short after claiming it made
his bride to be upset Yeah Yeah from
house hunting in Arizona with fiance
Lauren Burnham to celebrating at a wine
bar GQ got up close and personal with
the 36 year old for a profile piece
titled the most hated bachelor in
America explains himself
it was also Ari could share his thoughts
on season 22's shocking ending but the
reporter never got the full story that's
because after two days together Ari
refused to participate any further quote
I don't know how the conversation went
on your end but Lauren is really upset
adding I agreed to do this because I
believe it will be positive and shed
light on who I am and in no way did I
want to make Lauren upset I think our
interview is done gq's Rebecca Nelson
says she received those texts from Ari
after she talked to Lauren about her
initial reaction to being rejected by
the race car driver when he first
proposed to now Bachelorette Becca
cuffrin I choose you today but I choose
you every day from here on out this is
why I came on the show to meet someone
like her and it's made it all worth it
Lauren spoke out after the interview
dropped Tuesday taking to Twitter
writing she cried just a line nobody
should have to feel bullied in their own
home in another text Ari described his
time with GQ as a tabloid interview and
went on to cancel his planned photo
shoot with the magazine
ET has reached out to ABC for comment
[Music]
[Applause]